-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
and, now,
let's get to the news.
The Congressional Baseball Game
was last night
and the Republicans
beat the Democrats 13-12,
but only because Kyrsten Sinema
refused to tag anyone out.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
was shown on TV at last night's
Congressional Baseball Game,
talking on the phone
in the stands.
Even worse,
they caught her on the...
[ Laughter ]
Joint Chiefs of Staff
Chairman General Mark Milley
publicly testified
before the House yesterday
and said that there's
a possibility
that al Qaeda or ISIS
could reconstitute
in Afghanistan
in the next six to 36 months.
Damn, and I thought
the Comcast guy was vague.
"Yeah, we're sending
someone now.
He should arrive between April
and October 2023."
It was announced yesterday
that YouTube
will remove the accounts
of several
well-known
anti-vaccine activists.
So, if you want
anti-vaccine content,
all you have left is
Facebook, TV, radio, sports,
and airports.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
42% of registered
Texas voters believe
that Governor Greg Abbott
deserves a third term.
In fact, they think
he should be forced
to serve out the entire term,
whether he wants to or not.
In an interview yesterday,
New York Mayor Bill de Blasio
publicly asked Brooklyn Nets
star Kyrie Irving
to get a coronavirus vaccine
for the upcoming NBA season.
Well, good luck with that.
If I know Kyrie Irving,
he'd rather jump
off the edge of the Earth.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
met yesterday
with actor Woody Harrelson.
Pelosi said it was a frank
and productive discussion
and Harrelson said, "I did?"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
nearly 60% of millennials
will attend a Friendsgiving
celebration this year.
Also, Friendsmas and
Friendependence Day,
and whatever else
keeps them away
from their weird,
anti-vaxx relatives.
According to a new survey,
more than 60% of Americans said
that they regret not spending
more time outdoors as a child.
So, in a way, it's kind of good
I forgot my kids
at soccer today.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of Skittles
have announced they'll replace
the green apple flavor
with the original lime,
while the eaters of Skittles
have announced
that they thought those
were M&M's.
"Oh.
Oh, this is a terrible mistake."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
the aviation ranking company
Skytrax this week
released its annual list
of the world's top 100 airlines
and Delta Airlines
received the highest rating
of any North American
air carrier,
while American Airlines
got an honorable mention
for Most Creative
Customer Service.
[ Laughter ]
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.